so what I have for you today is a little
game what we're gonna play some would
you rather movie style all movie
questions so choosing between one or the
other and then briefly explaining why
okay so first up would you rather work
with a real animal or a CG creature CG
creature why because real animals are
very I have so many pets in my house one
of the reasons I do work is Tilly I have
four dogs three cats 14 chickens two
rabbits and more goldfish than I care to
think about that's like my dream come
true and I I'm living large I'm so
jealous would you rather play a
character that you could relate to or
someone that's completely different from
who you are
[Music]
I think character who's completely
different to you I think then then it's
more fun than you can be something
really weird and different after
spending so many years with this
particular character are there any
qualities in gobber especially how he's
grown over the course of the films and
the TV series that you want to take with
you after this whole experience
yeah his relentless positivity in the
face of utterly terrifying odds he's
like okay let's go I think that's a good
thing to put in your back pocket yes
would you rather work on a set with no
food or no caffeine no food normally
caffeine is essential that's my choice
and normally when I say that I am judged
for it so I'm glad we're on the same
page I don't understand why people have
to eat all the time
you could hear mealtimes yeah also food
in the middle of the day when you're
performing it kind of drags you down a
little it's like you and I know each
other
really oh yeah too much caffeine would
you rather have to fake sneeze or fake
vomit in a scene hate me
Oh normally I get the opposite yeah I
know I can fix both a buncha man that's
the reason why I buy on pets I feel like
that's the only thing that's helped me
get over my fear of vomit is cleaning up
my cat's vomit often Oh careful miss
very bad Oh what are you dragging foam I
imagined dragon vomit is probably like
lamb
never thought about yeah it's very fishy
would you rather have to work opposite
someone who will only stick to the
script
or someone that improvises way too much
scripty person
I'll have the script e person yeah yeah
cuz then you know what you're gonna get
that's fair that's a good point to wrap
this up with something a little bit
different I find that it's highly
unusual that we see one director get the
opportunity to complete his or her
franchise especially when it comes to an
animated movie so in your opinion what
is it about Dean that makes him
essential to this franchise because the
the soul of these movies is ham I mean
he writes them and he creates the movie
in the old fashion authors to bigger
world because there's too many people
involved but but he is he's the author
of these movies you can't have the book
without the author absolutely and having
worked on so many How to Train Your
Dragon movies with him for so long is
there anything about this particular
experience that you hope that other
voice work opportunities give you
because you've had a lot in addition to
this yeah I think that that what this
does is that so many times when you when
you do voiceover you're not really you
don't really know what you're gonna get
you know you just you say it and you
leave and then someone paints it ends
but with this you kind of knew it was
going to be okay right from the
beginning
[Music]